hi guys it's Inka so an artisanal ice
cream shop in LA has invited me over to
make two really unique ice cream flavors
with them which if I succeed they might
sell so let's find out
I am on my way to the airport right now
and I'll see you guys in LA hi I'm
Adrienne for Langan I'm one of the
cofounders of wanderlust Creamery we're
an artisanal ice cream shop make
everything in-house and all of our
flavors are inspired by travel today
we're having Ingo comes to make some ice
cream it's gonna be really fun I'm
finally here I wanted to do something
today that kind of represents my
background I'm half Taiwanese and I'm
half Hakan Chinese all the best desserts
come yes
Hong Kong egg tarts are so popular that
custard flavor put in some shards of
flaky carmelized puppet industry long
tea is superb Aegon Taiwan a mom would
always buy an apple pastries maybe we
can do it long infuse ice cream with
some pineapple pastry pieces in there
let's do it we're gonna start with our
base organic grass-fed dairy eggs a
little bit of sugar for this one we're
using 16 percent butterfat because we
want it a little richer to substitute
for creamy we're gonna add some
taiwanese along I picked this variety
because it's known for having like a
really buttery milky flavor I love that
we're just gonna heat that until it
swirly basically bringing the base to
just a low simmer oh you can actually
smell them
this is so cool now we're gonna take
this and strain it y'all ready oh my god
you can actually see this many tea
leaves in there I love it what did it
press down really hard on gosh squeeze
it all out oh my god do you want to
taste your connection
it tastes like really creamy pull the
tea it's not bitter is this so good I
would just eat it like this we're gonna
cut up our pineapple juice sugar
pineapple goodness now that we have the
long tea already done we're gonna set
that one aside and we're gonna start
with our egg tart ice cream we're gonna
separate some egg yolks egg whites in
here yes wow I am really bad at this
city yeah
[Music]
I have a spoon don't worry I did it
beautiful we're adding our base again
we're adding extra egg yolks to make it
bigger yogi it's this baby up break it
up this is pretty much warm I'm just
gonna put a little splash beautiful
color and then you're gonna add that to
this
that's not familiar to you that does to
give it more egg flavor we're using this
Indian ingredient called black salt
this is labeled egg farts it's literally
labeled egg farts because it smells like
egg for its smell it okay this is what
they used to make vegan eggs it gives it
more of that egg flavor without adding
actual egg you don't want to tasting too
much like parts if we add too much egg
it's gonna ruin the consistency of the
ice cream super eggy it tastes exactly
like a guitar like a creamier 8-year
version of it only thing missing is the
crust I baked up some sticks of puff
pastry so that when you scoop these kind
of just break and you can see the flakes
custard and then pastry and then act
like a never-ending egg tart now we're
gonna go ahead and pour this mix into
the ice cream machine okay let's go this
is a Ferrari of ice cream machines this
is the carpet Johnny LV 502 G perfect
Gian
we pour the mix in here and the mix gets
whipped with a blade as the barrel
freezes the ice cream creating super
tight microscopic ice crystals got it
oh my god
this is something a big egg tart
waterfall right here to the very last
row put the lid on and we're going to
have you press the magic button here we
go we'll come back I'm gonna open the
gate oh my god here we are almost four
gallons to stick them in and they're
gonna get broken up all the way down
[Music]
throw it right here in our blast freezer
we're gonna let it sit for about 15
minutes we did it first ice cream check
all right now let's do the belong round
two
[Music]
[Music]
Oh give me a panic attack oh my goodness
so now we keep on waiting alright let's
peel back this blue ice cream with
pineapple pastry bins
[Music]
there you go smell one time long but now
we should do one of this and then one of
the egg custard the Hong Kong big dirt
[Music]
look at how that tough patient wakes
apart I was so excited this is me and
ice cream for a little bit of this a
little bit of that I love the long waver
at the creaminess or custard it reminds
me of home is amazing
so if you guys want to eat this too you
should go it's waterless Creamery right
now because it's only gonna be there for
a short while I promise you it will be
worth the trip hey I'm sob is on a new
channel and now you're part subscribe
here that was my part